so the heading is trainable I'll explain
what that means and why it is called
what it is shortly but some of you will
have heard this phrase before what is it
why is it useful the best way to
understand it is to consider a question
being on DX I've introduced before I
call this the differential operator what
it means is find the derivative of that
if I ask you to find the derivative of
any function that's called Y then of
course this is where we get our dy/dx
which is just a fancy way of writing the
limit of gradient as a secant approaches
to become a tangent so I know it's a bit
notation heavy but that's the idea now
let the moment how would we approach
such a question what will react Chua lee
do suggestion x plus 2 cubed is totally
with the reach of us to expand because
we've done binomial theorem even if you
hadn't done binomial theorem you could
do the square that you could do it again
but we have the binomial theorem so
let's just quickly do this x + 2 + u
cubed is going to happen and x cubed
right oh it's been a while since we did
binomial ok then I'm going to try and go
through this all the way now you've got
your binomial coefficient it's going to
be 1 3 3 1 4 this one isn't it
so I'm going to go 3 the X the X is
quite down so I'm only going to have two
of them now and the twos are climbing
top so I'm going to have a 2 on the
event are you with me so far so there's
the three components of each term in the
binomial expansion we said 1 3 3 1 less
X 1 more 2 and in the very last term 2
cubed ok so if they don't want to draw
ranking a bit bigger just because the
first one is now that we've expanded
this of course we can actually work out
what each of these terms is and each
individual term we can differentiate
each one is just a power of X so we've
developed a rule for the
so the derivative of x cubed will be
will bring this throughout the front and
we will reduce the power by one that's
cool this is 6x squared in here 6x
squared so when you breathe ATAR at the
front you're going to get a coefficient
R 12 and then you bring the power down
by one that's going to be 12x
so the power is 1 so bring it around the
front does nothing
you're just a pub I want to make a Dero
which leaves you with 12 doesn't it what
happens to that 8 long the end you
differentiate it it just goes off to 0
because it contributes nothing to the
grain you okay
by the way another way of thinking about
this is if you've got any function and
you know what its derivative is okay
number one please say I'm doing the
derivative one of those common things
that people will write with their in
calculus mode they're like I'm really
good at differentiating is they'll just
do that because they're like that's the
next thing to do I like to call this a
violation of the equal sign because
those things are not equal so tell me if
you're doing something different what
that is now do you notice that the
derivative will not change if I do
something like that right because what
have you done to this graph like what
does the +3 do it it just shifts it
vertically okay so therefore it doesn't
change or anything to do with how steep
or shallow it is you just put it in a
different spot so therefore that number
consumed is nothing to the derivative
just like this one ok so we have a
derivative but that was somewhat
tiresome wasn't it even with a power as
low as 3 like we just we were having
trouble remembering how to do this right
let alone four powers four or five or
800 so how can we do this differently
what we want to do is consider this as
not just one function to be
differentiated but two functions X plus
2 is a function all on its own right and
cubing is also a function all on its own
so rather than consider this as a single
function I'm going to introduce the subs
tuition and consider it as two different
functions at same time let me show you
what I mean so make a little subheading
which is introducing a substitution so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
make up a new function right let's call
this original function y right and then
let's introduce a label and the
customary label is you I don't know why
but whatever you and I'm going to label
it as this function inside it's often
called the inside function right if u is
equal to that
I'm just letting that be the case I've
just introduced it then I can rewrite
the original function in terms of U
rather than in terms of X I can write Y
as a function of U rather than Y as a
function of X I'm just going to do a
substitution to replace everything right
in fact it's just going to be you cute
is it not okay now the nice thing about
each of these independent functions
you're like this is making a problem
worse not better you've got twice as
many functions to differentiate yes I do
but each of them is easier to
differentiate did you notice that right
for example have a look at this guy
right you remember we said D or DX is a
differential operator you can apply it
to anything you like well I'm going to
play it to you I'm going to do DX of U
since it's not D on DX of Y it's not dy
or DX it's D you on DX you're comparing
it to something else you're
differentiating something else so I've
just got a different label in here okay
and then I look at this and I apply the
same kinds of knowledge of
differentiation that I already have
what's the derivative of X on its own
it's just 1 because you do the same
thing with the powers you always do
what's the derivative to on its own
nothing doesn't contribute anything as
been pointed out so that's D u or DX now
when you have a look at this this is no
longer a function in X at least that's
not how I'd consider you so what makes
sense to differentiate this and look at
X's we would say differentiate it with
respect to X so instead of saying dy or
DX
I'm going to consider it in terms of the
variable that's it in terms of so third
dy DX it'll be dy on do you that's the
variable that's the input that goes into
this function still a function still got
one pair of variables there but it's
just different ones have a look at this
I know it's a different letter but it's
just a label that's all it is so you do
the same thing you do with all
differentiation bring the power out the
front and subtract one from the tower is
that okay right now here's the crucial
thing and it's why it's one of the big
reasons why I love dy DX notation so
much more than I love - notation even
though - notation is fast what it makes
clear is that you're comparing like rise
and run two different literal quantities
that change and so a fraction actually
makes sense as notation rather than like
f dash X which means just do something
to f of X this tells you what the do
something is and it helps you see
there's a relationship between these two
derivatives